also wieder freue ich mich richtig dass
euch jetzt zu zeigen gebt euch erstmal
als gastes geht euch mal das sweet
flavours butter karl may pringles bevor
wir weitermachen aber jeder auf jeden
fall alle den kanal es fehlen noch
ungefähr 30.000 bis zu den eine million
und ich hoffe wir schaffen das noch
dieses jahr das beim mega geil deswegen
ich würde mich sehr freuen und jetzt
gehts weiter
eine tosca und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ja weil ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht es gut
heute mal wieder aus meiner
wunderschönen okay ich wirklich liebe
diese location alltag und spaß nennt mir
einen youtuber der einen hässlicheren
hintergrund hat als ich also das ist ja
ich schäme mich schon ein bisschen dafür
muss ich wirklich fast sagen ich weiß
auch nicht was ich mir damals gedacht
habe als ich gedacht habe
hey du brauchst auf jeden fall auf ihren
diesem thema noch so eine kleine video
ecke das ist der reinste katastrophe
hier oder wolle man auch noch mit diesem
regal neben ich habe da jetzt versucht
so ein paar sachen reich zu tun aus den
letzten videos also ich hab die letzten
videos oft wenn ihr euch dafür
interessiert aber darum geht es
eigentlich gar nicht denn wir haben nach
sehr langer zeit habe ich mich auch
wirklich sehr normal gespielt ja ein
oder andere erinnert sich wahrscheinlich
noch dran ich habe vor dreieinhalb
monaten oder so mal diese videos gemacht
ich teste eine essens box aus dem und
dem land und ja wir hatten schon japan
was man da noch weil ihr land tansania
ich muss auch mal checken keine ahnung
auf jeden fall ganz verrückte länder und
wirklich auch ganz ganz viel süßigkeiten
und lebensmittel
und heute habe ich eine neue box
bekommen ich bin gespannt aus welchem
land sie ich hab noch nicht reingeschaut
jetzt haben wir wieder das probleme mit
der schere ich habe keine schere so nah
so jetzt vielleicht habe ich es mal und
eines habe ich da bin ich mal gespannt
ich mach das mal zu eurer seite auf aus
auf ich mach das mal zu eurer seite hin
auch so ist richtig schwierig heute
jubel ist leider nicht dabei da ist wenn
ich hier und wir haben ist das sind
hongkong geil alltag hongkong man ja man
das ist interessant da freue ich mich
drauf gemeint ich muss sagen also vier
schöne grüße an euch vernaschen die welt
macbooks nennt sich das ganze
die mir immer diese boxen zu sehen der
ja da sind sogar pringles so drin ganz
verrückt alter und wir haben ihn wieder
so ein schönes buch dabei wo dann die
ganzen süßigkeiten und lebensmittel
aufgeführt sind coca cola frohsinn lemon
genial leute ihr seid die geilsten also
wirklich darum für porsche die welt und
natürlich auch das video also gerne
immer weiter boxen einfach auf mich
zukommen lassen
taktisch sehr sehr gerne aus dann würde
ich sagen will aber gar nicht lange rum
ich muss mir auch ein bisschen beeilen
weil ich muss gleich zu dem geburtstag
von meiner oma und starten mal hier mit
ihr denkt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich dass
es ziemlich schwer aber es ist brutal
leicht suite monster konnten candy heißt
das schauen wir mal rein
ach ich trottel alter konnten kennen die
heißt ja auch zucker hatte
geschmacksrichtungen seoul hatte ich ich
will das mal raus alter eingepackte
zuckerwatte in sondergrößen verpackung
klar muss dann auch so groß sein aber
das habe ich auch noch nie gesehen liegt
auf jeden fall ganz nice ich probier's
mal
wir können ja mal so fluffig
auseinanderreißen geht nicht okay war
schon sehr intensiv riecht irgendwie so
ein bisschen ein alter geschmeckt aber
echt gut
man muss sich diese deutlich fester
vorstellen ganz zuckerwatte hier die es
irgendwie die konsistenz ist ein
bisschen fester und wenn man das
verstehen kann auf jeden fall neues
produkt ich habe meinen kommentaren sie
aufgelesen ließ doch danach die
beschreibung dazu vor das mache ich auch
also ab jetzt so konnten candy einmal
jahrmarkt rummel oder team ist für zu
hause kein problem denn mit dem konto
denn die haben wir hier schon fertige
zuckerwatte die auch oder den großen
trubel ganz gemütlich auf dem sofa und
habe ich mich schon sehr zuckerwatte was
eine überraschung so lassen wir hier mit
weiter haben wir haben wir ich denke mal
das sind so thies kekse weil was anderes
ja ich mache mal auch von der marke
frito lay aber wahrscheinlich so ley ist
es wird diese chips wie toll er keine
ahnung vielleicht ist das das
chinesische lace vielleicht auch nicht
das trägt aber nicht so gesund alter die
richten total nach nach knete genau
jetzt ist mir eingefallen
guck mal wie das aussieht da das so
lange chips oder ja wahrscheinlich so
einem chip sidebar schmecken aber also
die richter echt nicht gut wie gesagt
nach knete schmecken aber umso besser
hat wirklich leckere dips oder wie man
das auch immer geil
apropos chips ich zeige euch mal kurz
was ich hier gerade die ganze zeit sehr
also wieder freue ich mich richtig dass
euch jetzt zu zeigen
gebt euch erst mal als gast ist geht
euch mal das sweet flavours butter karl
may pringles ein teil das habe ich noch
nie gesehen aber ich glaube die sind
schon ziemlich zerstört da drin liegt
wahrscheinlich am transportaufkommen bis
nach deutschland
aber sehr interessant stelle ich mal
hierhin so damit jetzt schon sinken und
jetzt haben wir hier einfach froh sind
coca cola ich habe absolut keine ahnung
ob ich die ersten kühlschrank stellen
muss oder so kann man hier auch nicht
entnehmen wie ihr sehen könnt also da
steht alles mal auf chinesisch drauf
also dass tests mit euch auf jeden fall
noch jetzt habt ihr noch weiter sagt das
hier sieht auch interessant aus pandora
also ich denke mal das besondere art
keks oder so hatte halt auch wieder also
das ist halt das problem finde ich ein
sonntags ist halt in so einer
plastikverpackung eingepackt hat doch
dann wenigstens 20 keks in der größere
plastikverpackung damit es nicht
wenigstens ein bisschen lohnt so aber
gut erinnern mich sehr andere spanische
kekse ich weiß gar nicht wie die heißen
aber ihr könnt euch den geschmack
ungefähr so vorstellen ich weiß nicht
viele von euch dann wahrscheinlich noch
etwas jünger wenn man mal so einen
kaffee im restaurant bestellt oder so
unseren keks dazu bekommt so schmeckt
das eigentlich wieder kam ja auch nicht
bis jetzt hongkong auf jeden fall
zufrieden mal schauen was man noch so
ach guck mal koalabären gutmachen mal
mit was anderem weiter das problem ist
tschuldigung ich wollte mal kurz noch
lesen was das fix ist han doro diese
süßen butterplätzchen zaubern jedem ein
lächeln ins gesicht warum auch einen
normalen keks zum kaffee genießen wenn
es diesen panda keks gibt ja leute ja
ich und meine geschmacksknospen wir sind
einfach profi so machen wir hier mit
weiter wir haben einmal dass er cool
wenn du stehen bleibst wo stellen weil
ich war so rum und danach das ist glaube
ich halbwegs das gleiche zumindest sieht
es von der verpackung her so ausland
versteht halt nix also ich versteh gar
nicht was draufsteht wäre es jetzt
wenigstens auf englisch aber gut macht
ja auch sinn dass es nicht auf englisch
ist ich mache dir einfach mal auf und
dann lese ich gleich wieder was da
wirklich drin sein soll was ich erst
nach diesem 5 part von dieser essens
reihe hier weiß so asiatische
verpackungen sind sehr sehr oft so dass
man die so aufzieht und dann willst du
hier halt geben was raus und hier noch
mehr plastik raus ja ja und ja gut dann
treffen wenn ich das jetzt hier mal ach
so und jetzt soll man die hier rein
legen
das verstehe ich jetzt noch nicht ganz
egal wir machen das hier gleich mal mit
auf das ist doch was anderes jetzt komme
ich aber hier ein bisschen durcheinander
also wartet dann verstehen wir erstmal
das sieht aus wie so ein m & m was so
ein bisschen von schokolade ummanteln
wohl zumindest genau zur hälfte
ich probier s mal schmeckt auch ein
bistro und jetzt will ich aber mal kurz
lesen was das ist die süße schokolade
kommt in fünf verschiedenen farben und
geschmacksrichtungen daher die kleinen
eistüten aus feinster schokolade haben
natürlich auch ihre eiskugel obendrauf
so a
das sollte jetzt denke ich da ist das
soll in verschiedene eisbecher seien mit
eis drin aber was sie sollen habe ich
immer noch nicht verstanden dann ob das
jetzt auch aussieht wie eis also naja ne
aber schmeckt gut und das ist die
hauptsache ich komme mal zum nächsten
ist jetzt noch mehr drin aber ich habe
ja gesagt das muss dort mann der von der
gleichen marke seien leute sowas also
sieht ja ähnlich aus man mit so einem
keks drin
hier auf dich live jetzt habe ich schon
wieder irgendwie so ein kriegs im kopf
der so ähnlich schmeckt eigentlich bei
den anderen parks war es immer so da
habe ich auch immer zu juli gesagt er
hier entstehen rad richtig neue
geschmackswelten für mich das habe ich
noch nie so geschmeckt hier bei der
hongkong
inzwischen habe ich vieles schon mal so
geschmeckt was waren das jetzt hier also
es ist glaube ich auf jeden fall von der
gleichen marke und das hier ist ein
bizkit mit schokolade darum was sollen
baumstumpf für sein alter die kommen
noch auf ideen falls ihr das erkennen
könnt soll ein baumstumpf sein
ach so das steht dann so hier wer denkt
sich ein sonnenschein also jetzt kommen
wir hier zu diesem keksen die also ganz
krass die richten schon wieder so nach
knete ok also so sieht es aus und ich
probiere es einfach mal ein und die
schmecken halt wirklich süß das sind die
ersten promis in meinem leben die ich
also die süß schmecken das passt
irgendwie kann also es ist halt voll die
erfahrung so pringles wer von euch hat
schon mal krimis probiert die süß
schmecken schreibe es in die kommentare
wenn ihr die kennt also ich könnte sie
nicht na ja auf jeden fall leistung war
schon dass die hier dazu schreiben ja
hier steht sogar die chips sind ein
geschmackserlebnis dass ihr so bestimmt
noch nie erlebt habe richtig also kasse
wirklich lies eine sache die habe ich
allerdings schon mal so ähnlich glaube
ich bekommen von euch das war meine ich
tansania also leute effekt auf jeden
fall auch die anderen essens boxen aber
das ist wirklich mega interessant zu
sehen und hier haben jetzt also
praktisch wieso mikado es dann nur halt
mit strawberry umzogen auch wirklich
wirklich leid und das haben wir zum
schluss noch diese cola leute passt mal
auf coca cola frau slamanig zeigt sich
mal kurz in die kamera könnt ihr das
kalte getränk / ja nicht dass halb
gefrorene getränk gibt es in allen
erdenklichen sorten und schmeckt so
ziemlich jeden was ihr aber garantiert
nicht kennt coca cola frose lemon das
päckchen kommt in flüssiger form aber
wird zum / wenn ihr es für einige zeit
in euren eisschrank ja heute dann würde
ich sagen das mache ich doch und dann
sehen wir uns ein paar stunden wieder
wenn das halt so ein bisschen gefroren
ist oder eine einer stunde denken kommen
leute herzlich willkommen zurück hier
nicht so nach kneten irgendwie das echt
unglaublich lagen herzlich willkommen
zurück es sind jetzt 23 stunden
vergangen und ich hatte das jetzt
wirklich sehr lange im kühlfach es
allerdings gar nicht richtig gefroren
wie man erkennen kann keine ahnung warum
aber ist ja gar nicht so schlimm ich
habe mir gedacht ich will das mal hier
in einem glas damit ihr das mal sehen
könnt wie das dann aussieht sieht
wahrscheinlich aus wie normale cola ja
ja ja ich habe früher mal kühe gemolken
deswegen kann ich das so gut also
besonders viel ist jetzt nicht drin aber
wir haben hier also sieht schon aus wie
es fleisch als würde ich sagen oder was
sagt ihr dazu
ich probiere jetzt einfach mal
echt lecker ohne spaß richtig gut also
zwar sehr kalt das ist ja auch logisch
aber schon lecker
schade dass das in deutschland nicht
gibt also das wäre mal so eine sache für
den deutschen markt ich mache ja auch
öfter mal was mit coca cola schöne grüße
hier an dieser stelle überlegt euch doch
mal alle wir hatten wirklich keine
sachen dabei
das mega das hier egal ob diese
zuckerwatte extrem geil
leute ich würde sagen es war auf jeden
fall mal wieder ein geiler part lasst
doch nach oben da abonniert den kanal
und checkt gerne mal die instagram seite
ab von den hier schreibt einmal alex hat
sich sehr gefreut über das paket gerne
weitere damit weitere videos gibt weil
die sachen sind echt cool ist machen wir
mal eine menge spaß wir sehen uns
ansonsten morgen um 19 uhr wieder gibt's
neues video und das war es instagram
sich alex w